what's up guys don't worry about that
that we just had a little you know
little thing happened there we took the
stream down but we're back and um we are
back with the lady like I said before
who has got the best legs in the
manosphere he is just pretty things
right okay let's get straight to it
because this is the second time around
um let's get to it uh let's all go
around say your name relationship status
Naomi Alexander 35 and I'm single ish uh
Parham some people know me as Banksy
style I used to uh I'm single too old
and used to working corn
uh my name is Mariam and I'm 18 and I'm
single
my name is Tanisha I'm a PT and mindset
coach and I am taken
I'm Terence I'm 36 and I'm in a
relationship
my name is Aaron bz Burns uh my
relationship status is off the market
and my age is classified so for those
that don't know um we were doing a
stream before and I got pulled because
of copyright yeah
um so we're just gonna
um describe what the video was so go
ahead yeah yeah we saw a video on oh and
the topic today yeah the topic today is
true the topic today is men finding love
overseas and um yeah we just uh watched
a video which got taken down but we're
going to talk about it it was a video
from Good Morning Britain with Piers
Morgan and they were talking about
um finding love overseas there was a guy
speaking about him finding Russian
ladies specifically and how we found
them more attractive and the question
I'm going to ask is
are women from foreign countries better
wives than the ones
we currently have let's let's not let's
not limit it to Great Britain in the
West in general
are women better wives
let's go for a guy Banksy what do you
say
um well I've been recommending this for
a long time that men in the west due to
a myriad of reasons should start looking
elsewhere I spoke to a gentleman in
Australia about four years ago in
regards to him he was a pilot he had all
his house everything paid fully like
stacked a man was rich handsome and
generally uh you know in that top what
what you guys call the 10 10 20 and he
categorically told me that when he is
ready to get married he is going to get
married to a lady or a wife where he's
going to find them either in Vietnam
Cambodia Philippines and a country like
that he's in Australia himself very
wealthy in Australia but he will not
bring his wife to Australia he will
marry her and he will stay with her and
build a life in that country because he
knows that if he brings her to Australia
ultimately the feminists in Australia
will corrupt her and thus she'll be
looking for for for the ex said door
within a few years possibly a Visa
situation so in order to counteract any
of that he will marry in his 50s but he
will keep her in that country where the
laws are much more favorable in the
divorce courts to the men wow oh ladies
um
so do you feel that like he
she's gonna actually be marrying him
because she loves him and desires him or
that she just truly wants to get out of
the country of the poverty that she may
be living in to get to Australia to
wherever you were saying that she what
like he's from he's really wealthy so
he's then gonna like keep her in a
little box in the country that she's
trying to maybe get away from just so
that in order so he can control that
situation
do British women marry more for love you
think
I mean I feel that women automatically
marry from a place of feeling rather
than logic most obviously there's the
difference between logic and emotion and
the ram women that are more pragmatic
but I think generally women do go I
think we're into it I mean I think women
marry out of opportunity although so my
question is if so they why is the
average marriage seven to eight years
and why is the number one reason they
leave Financial if women in the west
America well because men are meant to be
the provider if we're going back to what
everyone says we're meant to be virgins
that's true it's true but at the same
time if we're talking about the
polarities of the masculine and The
Feminine energy if you want your wife or
your partner to be in her feminine
energy when I say a provider she could
still be working she could still be
doing her thing but in his energy being
the provider so looking after what's the
female energy is supposed to be in her
feminine obviously that doesn't mean
virginity but I mean it does
it means Purity that's what matters if
you look at the polarities of feminine
and masculine energy even within every
single person in this room there is
feminine and masculine energy that
doesn't say Purity you're not any less
feminine because you're not a virgin are
you a virgin people wouldn't say no
feminine I would say I would say I am
less feminine than I was like I was more
feminine when I was a virgin yeah I
definitely wasn't because every every
heartbreak makes you a little bit more
bitter oh I don't know
I think honest every every heartbreak
comes with some trauma at the same time
the more penises you have inside you the
more masculine you come yeah so I will I
would say I would say when I was a
virgin like I was like 100 but it
doesn't negate from the fact that you
are still able if you do the work to
step into your feminine energy if you're
with the counterpart that is in his
masculine I just think women are either
feminine or they're not to me and to me
like you can learn to fake it but like
you'd be like but you can always smell
it no if you do if you do the true work
on allowing yourself when I had my son
that forced me into my feminine energy
what what is like the because no offense
I I just hear this like do the work but
then like there's no work there is when
you go to when you do you work out why
you're in your masculine energy because
there is always a why to yourself so say
I'm too masculine and then so like I
find out it's X reason then what what do
I do what's the work whoa therapy okay
deep trauma work Shadow work there's so
many different things sound bath here
then Reiki here then there's so many
different types of work that you can do
therapy to maybe get over your father
wound which are your mother wound which
is usually where this I need to be in my
masculine energy in order to prove
something or even Society
yeah but this is they don't sound like
real things well I think sometimes women
can be quite masculine because they have
not met a man that has allowed them to
to be in their feminine energy so
sometimes and they feel like you know
they're not with the right man that is
allowing them to take a step back and be
in that feminine energy and to like lead
them differently sorry so do you think
that femininity is conditional then
conditional like do you think that it
depends on the condition just like
masculinity yeah no it's not because
I've seen many [ __ ] out here let me
tell you something as a man if I said
I'll be masculine for the right woman no
no no no you're gonna look at me and say
what you're gonna be like what do you
mean I'd be masculine for the right
woman but you say you'll be feminine for
the right man and you think that makes
well because he's meant to be the leader
he's a leader you're meant to lead so if
you're if you're you're meant to be in
your if I'm meant to be in my master I
think we have not meant to be in your
feminine yeah but I think we have
masculine and feminine energy and I
think if you're a woman and you're with
a man that doesn't allow you to step
into your femininity because he's not
masculine enough then you're masculine
side kind of comes out and compensates
for that
I disagree I just think that's an excuse
that women want to use as an excuse to
be masculine I I just think that's an
excuse like like the most
picture-perfect feminine women I know it
doesn't matter who they're with they're
feminine regardless I just think you're
either feminine or you're not feminine
for stars I agree with what she just
what Paul just said about him
do you think it works both ways so
basically if you're uh slightly
masculine female
because you're not with the right guy
that can bring out your femininity do
you think
a man will get away with saying he's a
slightly feminine man because he's not
with the right woman yeah maybe a man
can be with a woman that's maybe a
little bit too masculine for him and
then it doesn't allow him that
confidence to step into his masculinity
it's all about that
the question is
would you give a guy who's very much in
his permanent energy a chance nope
probably not because I just feel like I
want a man to lead
because I'm sure that uh you know
females in their masculine energy would
like a man to give them a chance I mean
just imagine this imagine if a guy just
started like being like hey girl hey
girl
I mean with some masculine females had a
lot like it's crazy like that would
sound nuts to you crazy but we can like
never fat spew this is like nonsense to
me I just think you're either a feminine
woman or you're not a feminine woman but
I think sometimes the thing is I'm sorry
there's a this is something where most
people who've done any kind of training
martial arts anything else they say you
are your habits you are what you train
if you train full contact you punch full
contact if you train semi-contact you
throw semi-contact you are your habits
it is incredibly difficult to live your
life for most of it or for decades as a
masculine woman and then suddenly turn
on the feminine but you can train it
though you can train yourself
but the thing is
does a man train you or do you train
yourself well it depends if you can
relationships can bring out that side of
you to do that because a lot of the time
when you get into a relationship the
reflections and the trauma that is
brought up where then it forces you into
that space of like you know what
actually maybe I am not doing something
in this relationship that's not allowing
this man to do what he's meant to be
doing and so then it forces you to look
to get that mirror and be like you know
what I need to do the work on me sorry
outside of therapy what else
because I just imagine like if you're
gonna change your whole temperament like
there's a lot that's in it so I mean I'm
sure it take well no it does take many
years therapies that probably so not
outside outside the therapy
um
a lot of stuff I can't say I can't say I
wouldn't like to but do you think like
this is the thing about like women that
say this kind of stuff men here we don't
want masculine women no we don't want to
be massive we don't need that but what
I'm trying to say what I'm trying to say
is like you say oh we've got to train
ourselves to be feminine right
reprogramming I'll reprogram yourself or
re-jig yourself whatever it is get
yourself download a new program well
it's like going to the gym but men
generally don't they ain't got time for
it now if if it's the princess if if we
take you on a date for instance right
and we see that you're more masculine
than you are feminine we're already
calculating like this is going to be a
problem it's going to be a problem and I
haven't got time because I don't know
you like that we haven't got time to be
trying to program you and you're trying
to train you into being more
feminine like we want if we go on a date
with you we want a woman that we can see
she's kind of feminine I kind of like
this do you know what I mean and then
we'll pursue it but masculine women we
don't want to train you because if we
say the word because you use the word
train no I did it yeah you asked me a
question whether a man can do can help
you in that and so I I didn't say
because a lot of the work the Deep work
that I've done I've done on my own not
for like yes relationships have
presented these mirrors for me time
which every relationship presents
mirrors could be a relationship with
your mum your friends can present these
spaces of where you're like okay I've
got to work on myself in this and
understand sometimes you don't need to
say this so you don't need to say that
oh you can take a step back and
understand that yes this man can lead me
so I'm not saying that it's a man's role
or job to do that that's a Twist of
words do you think you need a man to
co-sign it though
and so like if you know you did this not
not just you but anyone that does like
the Deep work the femininity training
like would you say that there has to be
a man that co-signs it because like
women Lie To Each Other Well I think
that when you get into a relationship
you'll then when you take time out maybe
after a relationship and then I think a
relationship will let you know how
successful your deep work has been
because you're not going to know how
successful you're going to be in a
relationship so you're in a relationship
right so the thing is I wouldn't say a
man because you could be a lesbian this
is like Beyond cap
um
it's like the amount of cap here is like
or cope are you married
um I was engaged for a long time but the
thing is that's that what I see here is
like the women saying oh when I meet the
right guy I'll then turn it turn on the
femininity whilst actually in the
realities they don't actually even turn
on the femininity they just go you just
can't handle a strong woman yeah and
then you as a man are berated and
ridiculed because you can't handle this
incredibly masculine learn energy of
this woman that's coming at you all day
long because you don't want that you
want feminine submissive and beautiful
women and so that's I think part of the
reason why men in the west are actually
going abroad whether it be Dominican
Republic Brazil certain parts of Africa
um Eastern Europe
um Thailand Philippines that's why
they're going there to kind of find
wives because what what a lot of them
are saying and I've heard it a lot from
men that Western women are too much work
so too much work sorry so I'm interested
to know like what do we feel is
femininity and what are feminine traits
and what uh considered too masculine uh
for a female to to kind of be I think
what are the traits the femininity
Community is so interesting to me I was
going on a rant on Twitter about this
because they're just so they're so broad
they just say like a lot of nothing in
different ways
um when I when I think of femininity I
think of like nurturing I think of like
typical like motherly traits
um however I've found that there's no
real way to like measure it or show
anything or show any work or really so I
don't know it's so broad that's why it
really confuses me is that that's that
Community I'm interested because I think
sometimes I can be seen as being in my
masculine energy because why why would
you say that for a while I was a single
mother and I was doing everything by
myself and I was very much used to okay
this is down to me I'm gonna do this by
myself everyone's relying on me I can
get on with it you're not a single
mother anymore okay okay you're married
um I'm not married but I have a partner
yeah so I was very very kind of used to
doing everything on my own that's me
I've got this kind of thing and some
some people some men would consider that
too masculine so I'm just interested
is it okay yeah I looked it up I was
just I I saw this chart when I was going
on my rant on Twitter that I tweeted so
I was trying to find it
um feminine um not aggressive dependent
easily influenced um submissive passive
home oriented easily hurt emotionally
indecisive talkative gentle sensitive to
others feelings very desirous of
security cries a lot emotional verbal
kind nurturing tactful another chart
says intuitive generous nurturing
creative collaborative caring receptive
grateful which I agree with those I
agree with those statements but like
when you said that um for me when I had
my son was when
my level of femininity had to come out
automatically interesting because you
just said that when you had your
children your masculinity came out yeah
because I felt like I had to be I was a
single woman before that but I had a
girl so my first daughter my first child
was a girl but when I had my son like my
son is very very affectionate very very
he he just brought out that side of me
that needed to nurture him in a way and
also I didn't want him to
grow up thinking that men women are in
their masculine they're angry like I
wanted him to see the calmness and the
Stillness and for him to be able to
communicate with me openly because it's
not taught to young men that you can
communicate you could like if he's upset
I don't go in shouting at him I don't
shout I don't raise my like I very much
bring the femininity to my son all the
time I have a question
um all right so you're not in a
relationship I didn't
know
so now
are you sure
it's Alex I mean there might be a
relationship maybe there's a guy you
like yeah okay okay okay okay and then
you're in a relationship no I know
you're not you're in a relationship
would you guys
um if you guys were to marry the person
you're talking to or talking to in a
relationship with would you quit your
job if you told you to
no questions asked if if I'm married if
I've married him if I if I if I'm
married if I've married him it means I
trust him to lead and I would trust his
decision in that and I would trust that
it's for the best interest of our family
okay yeah you would yeah so if he said
to me oh sorry
so if he said to me you know I I think
you should you quite work and I'd be
like yeah again I trust him in that and
I'm ready for that because I feel like
he's allowed me to step into that
feminine energy and I don't I no longer
have to be like right I need to be on it
I need to do this I need to do that on
my I'm on my own I'm not on my own
anymore I can trust him lean into him
and yeah so I would I'd love that
actually what about you same I would
really love that I think I would be like
I'm really ready to settle down now like
I would think about kids so I think yeah
like if he is in control and if he's
leading this whole marriage then I would
say
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah because I feel like he must have
worked something out and
yeah
I
think the difference between Western
women and women from abroad like taking
it back to the subject is that the women
from abroad
would probably be more submissive and
not question as much and I think I don't
know I want to ask the guys here right
do you think that the women
from the west or women abroad would make
better wives for you guys
you know what ah for starters
I haven't had problems getting
submissive women in the UK
but
um I think I'd say 50 of the
people have been in long-term
relationships with have been
even if they live in the UK they've
they've had their formative years in
another country right and
very I'm not going to say submissive I'm
going to say very feminine like um I've
heard people say you know we both have
masculine and feminine energy in us but
all the women I've been with I can't
even imagine them being supremely
masculine at all like they're so
feminine that even when they're trying
to do masculine type things it just
comes off feminine and that's feminine
you must be asking like what countries
they were from respectively
um the one I'm really thinking about now
she was based she was brought up in
South Africa okay and another one I'm
thinking of she was like hot she was
rich her mom's Filipino so right you
know
um and a Filipino that wasn't born here
yeah right so she's got that influence
yeah I think I think ultimately women in
the west are brought up to be more
independent whereas women in different
cultures may be brought to be
independent But ultimately are brought
up to serve the man so based on that
they're wired differently and they have
different goals into or they have they
play different roles in comparison to
women in the west when it comes to
marriages and relationships so it's just
yes that's what it is basically yeah and
also I just want to piggyback off that
and see
um
I think a lot of women in the west they
look at it as it's almost like a job
that they they kind of have to do to
look after a man whereas other women
raising other parts of the world
they look at it like they want to do
this right yeah and I I find whenever
I've um been with a woman long term or
just even dated them short term they all
seem to want to do feminine things for
me like you know they want to do my hair
they want to cook for me I've never had
to ask a woman to cook for me
I mean it might be something about my
energy as well I don't know but I think
that factors into it as well yeah yeah
well that that brings me to another
Point um you know the guy on the clip
that we can't show yeah
um you know he said he did well over
here uh but it's just that in Russia he
went to Russia because there's more
there's just more of what he wants and I
really don't see a problem with that by
the way you know if you think that
you're gonna have more options more of
what you like in a certain country why
why wouldn't you go but from what I've
seen is that there's a lot of women
because they called the passport Bros
shout out to the possible Bros
shout out to the passport Bros
um there's a lot of women in the west
now trying to shame passport Bros men
who are actually going on the cliff I
know yeah yeah and they they look like
bullies going up I think it's a delivery
I don't necessarily think because you
can have a choice and a preference of
whatever you want I think it's a
delivery of shaming another type of
woman just because you like something
else it's like the oh I like this
because this person you you're prefer if
that's your preference you like women
from Russia then say that and say I want
I want to go here but you don't have to
like give the reason is because of just
say you like that I think but I think
the stuff he said was true it was true
yeah and like we we are more overweight
yeah UK they always talk [ __ ] about the
us but y'all ain't in here
your obesity stats are better but not
much
we follow America we're like little
puppies after America that's the thing
like and we are less submissive in the
west the women the women
um outside of here were raised more to
be wives and like instead of instead of
shaming man for like saying what's true
I think we should say you know maybe we
should try to learn from them
shout out to Pearl's wife yeah I'm gonna
be on it I need
but the thing is is I was engaged to get
married but it's like do I stay in that
relationship where he's gonna
continuously cheat on me just so that I
can be a wife no you don't get points
for almost I didn't ask for points no
I'm just saying that I've been engaged
too but I never got one but my point is
is that do I like for me to get across
that line of like yay I can be married
do I then have to be that submissive
that I then put up with being
but you're not a virgin you weren't a
virgin for him right you had children
we've got children yeah yeah no I'm
saying were you a virgin no no no no no
no no that's what I'm saying like in a
way we cheat on our husbands by not
saving Purity for them
and we're gonna shame them for cheating
no no I would cheat on us too
would you would you stay in a marriage
if he cheated on you you got kids no no
yeah I I hell yeah if you got kids if
you got kids
but it's also then teaching your son
that it's okay to be
he's a blueprint so automatically no no
his dad is constantly I'm not going to
be happy yeah
I haven't told him but at the same time
I'm not going to be me it just looks
like mommy's not happy
don't you think you're in control of
your happiness you don't think it's a
choice yet my choice is to not stay in
that relationship that's going to
continuously cheat on me so I'll be
happy my son has brilliant right but
that's that's what I'm saying so like
you're putting your happiness over
what's best for the kids and that's like
all a while a lot of time having a happy
and that's that's why a lot of times
like men are leaving for the West
because it's like women here like think
it's about us when it's not about us
it's about the family first and and I
know like and and the other thing is one
out of three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the last year under
30 like there are men that you could
pick that would be faithful to you but
if you if you go for a guy that's
attractive to you he's going to be
attractive to other women I was gonna
ask you was he a top 20 man no
was he the type of man that other women
wanted of course right okay so what
happened is you probably chose a top 20
man because you were attracted to him
right he was and who is also attractive
to other women caveat women find 80 of
men as unattractive so if you found him
attractive he's probably in the top 20
percent right so so what happens is
there's a top 20 man who's got 80 of
women to choose from right I'm not and
so I'm saying and I'm not condoning what
he's doing I'm just saying if a man is
in the top 20 and he's got 80 of women
throwing in throwing their panties at
him right at some point in time he might
take that option and I'm not saying that
it's right or wrong I'm saying women
generally go for men right that other
women find attractive of course because
you don't go for men who you know work
at Starbucks and they're stacking
shelves generally and you don't go for
those men so what happens is part and
parcel of choosing a guy that other
women like
you've got to put up with being cheap
I'm not saying you've got a problem
I mean I really honest me as a parent
now in comparison to me as a parent when
I would because obviously I had a
daughter me the the mother that my son
has
now and my ability to give him the calm
from my feminine energy I wouldn't have
been able to do in that relationship so
for me 100 my son gets the best of me
out of that relationship can I can I
just simply say um for the lady with the
Sun
I don't think you'll have to worry about
any influences from outside of of your
husband or anyone else that your son's
gonna learn how to cheat you'll learn
your son will know how to cheat yeah of
course when it gets older when when
women simply offer themselves to it yeah
of course so there's no this is again I
see that as a cope it's like my
happiness I got rid of him because yeah
exactly again it comes down to you so it
was actually your personal choice for
your well-being not your sons Not Your
Daughters it was really your I'm sure
so do you I'm just curious do you you
think your happiness is more important
than the family and your son's happiness
my ability to feed into my children
determines my 100 if I my cup's not full
okay then I'm not able to offend my
children
and you don't you don't 100 you don't
and you don't think you control your
emotions in any way not back then no I
was so young I was like in my early 20s
which I understand maybe I was like in
hindsight would you say it was a mistake
being with a 100 no not being with him
leaving him no no he would do that I
would do it at exactly 100 you know
what's interesting is because uh like
even last week I was I was talking about
um I actually watched a tick tock video
and I say it was on Tick Tock but it was
actually a conversation between a man
and a woman who had just divorced her
husband yeah and he was asking her why
did you divorce your husband and she was
saying
he was too
good with money
and this is what she was saying she was
saying he was he liked to save
didn't like to spend
you know he was a little bit he was
always talking about oh we gotta say for
a rainy day blah blah blah right and she
left him
because he didn't do the things that
made her happy
but what he was actually doing
was doing that
to secure the family unit which right
and so when when a woman says if I'm not
happy then I'll do X Y and Z this men
have to watch I would say men have to
really watch out for women who care
about their happiness over the actual
family structure because that means that
because you know as a woman your
happiness fluctuates from week to week
from day to day from month to month when
this happens deep depression they're two
different things but I'm trying to but
what I'm trying to say is a woman is so
led by her emotions right and a man is
more so led by a lot pragmatic pragmatic
right and so we when a woman says things
that oh because I wasn't happy that's
why I left in in my in my head I don't
know about the other man I'm like red
flag
there's happiness and then there's being
like if you're a concert it's not like
I've left at the first cheat like I
didn't just be like yo bye peace out
thanks this is fantastic not at all it
took a lot for me to get to that point
too well I didn't I did not want to be a
single parent again how did you find out
about the cheating
um he had a whole relationship with her
my son was she phoned him and I answered
and we were in and she was having a
whole Affair yeah and she was crying
down the phone saying oh he told me that
these two weren't together and
um yeah anyway I won't go too deep into
it but what did he say about it
he tried to deny it obviously
you took her word over his
she provided me with enough evidence to
prove that that her
um you know truth to it and then
eventually he was sending flowers did
you did you ask him why he cheated
he just says every vagina like it's just
a different vagina that was his response
did you do you believe him yeah yeah
yeah you don't think it was actually
emotional not for no I think with
um he's like so opposite to me he's like
the opposite and he's so pragmatic so
logical so like we see the world isn't
that what attracted you to him
no he's really funny he's really tall as
well not joking I was eight why are you
giving it away
to be fair when I met him I was
at war in Iraq and it was
[ __ ] 50 degrees and then I I think it
was more the fact that we were both in
the military and so when you're both in
the military you have an understanding
it would be in a way for like it there
was a lot of things that went into me
ending up with my son's dad one thing I
think I just want to highlight uh Pearl
you had a guest that was a Pakistani
lady who had uh and her father had an
entire different family in Pakistan that
to me goes to the heart of the the
culture and sort of rooted
um you know values that certain people
from different countries have here is a
lady who's had a husband cheat on her a
couple of times I'm out here's another
lady who had her husband have an entire
different family yes
the relationship she didn't know about
it and that's that's the thing like like
Western women were not ride or dies it's
like one problem and we're out
and especially like he didn't even
emotionally cheat how do we expect but
like I don't think you could really
expect him I don't think he's gonna
think I don't think you can expect
monogamy if you're not a virgin like I
think you deserve monogamy if you're a
virgin but if you're not like you're
kind of cheating on your future husband
I think I deserve emotional um stability
like in the sense that it's the lies the
gaslighting that like you know as a
woman your intuition can pick up on
certain things and if you're being
gasoline so many times and you're like
am I going crazy is it like is so for me
it's maybe if I even broke it down even
deeper was it the act of having sex with
somebody that hurt me or was it all the
lies and the like the making me feel
like I was crazy
was it like you asking where he was was
it texts
um yeah if you ask a question and they
they there's just little things because
there were so many times that it
happened that it was like it wasn't the
first believe it it wasn't the first
time so what do you think you would have
done if he just told you the truth I'm
gonna start with you've stuck around
still or do you think you still would
have left well I've been in polyamorous
relationships so it's not like like
after as I've got older I've understood
the complexities of men and understood
that sometimes if I'm not able to give
my partner something that he potentially
maybe can seek from somebody else maybe
I'm open to that I'm open to the
conversation but if you take away my
right of choice like choose like I get
to choose whether I want to be like with
like that person and also like when it's
polyamorous it's very open and you know
who that person is and the energies
they're being brought into your home and
stuff after you had your son with him
what if he chose to say look I want this
to be polyamorous now how would you feel
it would have to be a discussion I don't
know because well he's saying I'm I'm
doing this regardless yeah but then
that's not a discussion that's just
that's him telling me something so so
you would have been out then basically
no I'd have the discussion I don't know
how I would have felt in that maybe if
it was probably Emery works both ways so
maybe if I can if it's good for the
goose is good for the Gambler right so
maybe if I can have my emotional
connection that he maybe wasn't giving
me all the Deep conversations maybe I
can get that from somewhere else did you
actually believe that really what you're
saying to me do I believe in what do you
believe that you would have actually
given it a chance
yeah that was like however many years
ago I'm a very different person today
the person you're talking to now is a
very different person to who left
whenever but back then so see you had
this you had your child oh no you would
have left yeah I would have left
so you said it was the light so you said
it was the lies but you know yeah but
he'd already lied at that point you're
talking about was he cheating before you
had had your child listen I said that
before you had your children
do you think that's sexual do you think
why did you do you think so why'd you
have a song
do you think that sexist man that what
um attention is to women
I I think men seek intimacy through sex
so I think they don't know how to be
intimate honest so like on in different
ways yes or no um
do you think sex is to men what
attention is to women yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so would
you argue that we cheat on men by having
open Instagram accounts while in a
relationship why I
got a question I I said is sex to men
what attention is to women you all said
yes please don't change it now
so could we argue that we cheat by
having open Instagram accounts while in
a relationship
nine posting first track wow
they're the same they're the same right
please don't go back attention
so so women so women love attention yeah
men love sex and Men love sex right so
if you love attention the the the
dopamine Rush that you get from with all
these likes and all this all this stuff
right
and imagine you've got a man yeah right
however you're posting all these
pictures and you're getting this
dopamine rushing all these guys saying
oh my God you're beautiful oh my God so
you're amazing thank you do you think
that's the same as cheating no
emotionally think so I think everywhere
you go men look anyways not not like
I feel like you get stared at anyways
everywhere that you go when you post on
Instagram so I don't think it's like
cheating I just think it's like I mean
you're choosing to post on Instagram
though yeah but now how was that cheap
though I mean you're posting Instagram
pictures
why don't you just take the picture on
your camera roll and keep it there why
because you feel you when you take a
picture and you and you look at it you
feel wow like this would be good for my
Instagram
so okay so you put it on your Instagram
so what would be the difference because
remember the pictures to make you feel
good yeah so so what would make you feel
good on Instagram
the likes the comments okay the
attention yeah okay okay yeah so so
we're back
and what I'm not doing I'm not trying to
advocate for cheating I don't think it's
okay I just think we have to understand
where the guys are coming from you can
have we we expect monogamy and we judge
them for cheating but yet we're not
virgins yet we have open Instagram
accounts yeah yet we come in with a
child it's like and then we're gonna say
be faithful to me and they're like what
but I think it should just be a
discussion so like if it's if it's a
case of you know what
I want to still do this open Instagram
thing and you're in a relationship and
he openly wants to go and have sex with
other people it's the conv have the
conversation yeah like have that
conversation yeah but the thing is hang
on but the thing is are most women ready
for that conversation hell no and plus
you can't get back your virginity no no
I'm not about getting back here
I'm mostly because the thing is I'm
convinced that meant that a lot of women
like men that cheat right I'm actually
convinced a lot of women like men are
cheap why um yeah because because once
they cheat because okay because you you
you openly choose men that you know are
attractive to other women you open you
you as a matter of fact you negate all
of the regular dudes you're like it's
lame he's regular I don't like him
you need negate the regular deeds and
you go for the dudes that you know that
all the other women want to but you feel
special because you're like I got him no
I got him hang on hang on hang on
however you feel but you know that there
there are plenty of women that are going
to be throwing their knickers and
throwing their panties at this guy right
and so you know that there is a
potential for that guy to be in a
situation where he's gonna cheat because
women find him attractive so so so you
don't choose men that are average
looking average earning an average
height you know that you choose men that
are you want to choose men that are
above average in all of those categories
my son's dad was earning the same as me
okay you guys guys would you date would
you would you do a five eight it's like
six free okay okay guys would you date
wait wait would you date a five eight
how much was the average salary here 35
95 35k okay five eight thirty five
thousand dollars slightly over 25 pounds
sorry pounds thirty five thousand pounds
slightly overweight guy all right yeah
okay so I have a question
it depends what average is okay like 35
000 pounds but I don't ask people I
don't ask people what they earn okay but
you can roughly know based on his job
based on his lifestyle you can you can
make assumptions I have I have dated
somebody slightly overweight no he went
to the gym a lot because I worked in the
gym at the time so okay so so he wasn't
he wasn't average above average okay no
she said she already said no no no no
okay I feel like No One's Gonna believe
me but I would because depending on how
he treats me is that your man right now
does your man fit that aesthetic right
now describe your man right now no but
I'm I'm not I would not I would not shut
that down we don't believe someone
approached me I knew you wouldn't
believe me someone approached me and I
felt like you know they've got a good
vibe and they approached me in the right
way and we got along then that wouldn't
automatically be a nah I'm hearing so
much happier that you should be wearing
this
had friends that go for guys that are
just like not in that talk about your
friends
but
by example that friends and you're like
okay this guy is just like you know
she's gone for the below average guy
what not and he cheated yeah and
everyone was like but then he's not
average something about him is above
average women don't cheat like cheat
with average men he might have trauma
Charisma yeah
women find 80 of men so if you ask girls
like you find this guy attractive you
they did this thousands of times they
took data from dating apps women only so
I brought five percent of the time so if
he can see it when you know how hard it
is
is it 43 yeah roughly 45 yeah absolutely
and you women know right you women know
you know that there are men who are
broke homeless
slinging dick
and but they're broken homeless and
they're slinging dick because there's
something about them because they they
fit an aesthetic right but there are
guys who are stable yeah got gen um
they've got an average wage who ain't
getting no play well as we said one in
three men in the last year have not had
sex that's kind of a virgin I have a
question just show of hands um would you
delete all social media if your partner
asked yeah um yes or yes just raise your
hand
yeah yeah
when I was 18.
yeah I just I just want to throw this in
as
IA
Instagram and Snapchat in a relationship
Snapchat Snapchat isn't that where they
people send each other like naked
pictures to each other
that's one thing I do want to say that
yes it is true that the 20 guys which
are pretty much these guys over here uh
do get a lot of attention
I'm just keeping it real but it is not a
lost cause if you're out there anyone
out there who is five eight chubby and
generally over the over the hill no if
you're right if you're a child
your mouth can play a big part
are you talking about what comes out of
it yes it's what you can say you I mean
don't get me wrong you can never talk a
10 into into a bedroom you you will have
to have other assets but there are
people like myself I found myself in my
niche of because there's a course of
studies called the Pandora's Box and
they did an assessment of women's
psychologies and some women like the the
lover and those who go for the provider
and so depending on which Camp you fall
into recognize Where You Are are and
I've always been in the provider Camp
Far More Than The Lover Camp no woman
has looked at me and goes oh gotta have
him but they've been like oh he makes a
good husband he'll probably make a good
uh father right and so I can always
swing that and and and you know be
successful in my particular Turf so
there is hope and there is but you gotta
know you know they said that for every
fisherman there's a fishing hole find
your fishing pole and fish in your pond
and if you fish in your pond you'll be
successful all the time if you're
fishing on Instagram and you're you know
you're a five foot guy with with thirty
thousand pound as an average and you're
trying to pick up the the hot Instagram
models that may be out of your league
just go to the pub but yeah find your
fishing hole and you'll be very
successful I've had amazingly good
looking women for my I have punched way
above I'm talking punched Mike Tyson
level above my weight and I even was
shocked that this woman is having sex
with me
[Music]
she we were working towards that I'll be
honest
I actually bottled it because I I think
this there's a there's a there's a
concert in pickup Artistry called
worthiness and I felt I wasn't worthy of
this woman I honestly I was I was I was
in a very different mind space and do
you think she felt that as well she
wanted to get married she wants us to
move in and I was like you are an
unbelievably good looking for me Banksy
um and you can tell me if you don't want
to answer this if it's online
um because she lets you as a provider
you say absolutely uh what are you
paying for everything
um I mean some things but I mean let's
put it this way if if you're talking
about the split it would be like 80 20
me I would I would book things she paid
for like dinners occasionally because
she was still the modern although she
was Iranian she was still had enough of
a modern British sort of values to say
look I don't want you to pay for
everything I'll pay for this one yeah
but the thing is that's that if she
didn't do that the first few times we
went on a date it would not be any
further because for me it's like I've
got three date strategy if she's not
picking up a check or offering more
importantly offering to pick up the
second or third check
I know that this is going in the
direction that I'm not good man isn't
that in her masculine energy though like
if you know
it's just a question it's just it's a
reciprocity sort of process I just want
to feel that this is she's not just
taking me for a ride I'm not just some
yeah
femininity is being kind yeah so it's
like it's kind if you offer to like buy
him dinner or something I think it's
masculine if you're like I need to pay
for everything no but if you're like
baby let me get it yeah
it's a good way of cigarettes but it's a
good way of figuring out if um
it's a good way of figuring out if
someone's trying to use you because
quite often what happens is um you know
you say there's a camp where women put
uh men into the provider cab where they
put them into the lover cup and quite I
I honestly think all women really want a
lover uh but depending on the situation
they're in in their life you know they
might need a provider so I think a lot
of men get used as providers but she
might be cheating with a lover
or even if she's not cheating she's
wishing she was and then she's treating
the provider
not very well yeah you know and and
eventually divorces him like what's the
snap on divorce like how many women
leave 70 to 80 of the time 90 of she's
college educated in the and I think the
I don't want to misquote this but I
think the reasons that men file like
tend to be along the lines of infidelity
and abuse um where women follow file the
number one reason is financial well
there you have it folks that's crazy
yeah yeah no further questions Kevin
Samuels did say that although something
like 70 80 percent of women file for
divorce if you're if the man is earning
below I think it said 100 of 80 000 and
if he's above 200 000 that drops to like
20 yeah yes that's true if um if a man
makes over a certain amount of money um
yeah I think it drops to 25 yeah uh po
uh before we get to the second half of
the show we're gonna read the super
chats and Super Chat time
and we can see what everybody thinks of
what people have been saying let's read
the super chats okay I'd like to say
these are not my opinions they are the
opinions of the chat that's right
um also guys like the video subscribe to
the channel um we are very close to nine
or 750 000 subscribers
um we're trying to hit up I don't think
we will but you never know um you know
shoot High we're trying to hit a million
by New Year's so you never know
um okay q q dub a woman's job is to put
you in a compromising position to find
out if to put you in a compromising
position to find out if she is the best
guy don't cry if you do so it's only for
emergency only
um wait is this from yesterday can
modern women be met hold on I think I
gotta refresh this that sounds familiar
yeah I was like I think I read this I
think I'll watch it this morning
I didn't refresh the page guys I'm sorry
okay Elite gamer 876 um no one wants a
strong and independent we want feminine
and confident 90 of free-toe pie
most women hate cheating because they
think they are special that no man would
dare cheat on her women don't look for
love they look for the perfect picture
um Lawrence Bullock if a woman is on
Instagram and is in a relationship but
post sexy pics like she's single that's
a form of cheating I'm 90 free-toe pie
most most men want women to be grateful
that's it you can have your pot you can
have your past and
um your past and your Instagram but if
we are together then Respect My
Sacrifice being with you I'm Auntie
Jenny I read your question earlier um
numbers guys zero cheating men is the
hive mind short circuiting on itself
can't put up with a cheating man but 100
pre-selection certified
um The Naughty Bear um bear that Pearl
you'll be my number one bear bee will
take a vacation you choose bare Betos
bear Hamas
Elite gamer 876 make a decision ladies
and either enjoy the life a successful
man provides and accept that he has
strayed or be self-righteous and live
alone and single forever
um Vinnie valcone um the question is
effing brilliant um Jonathan Farley I
went to Russia to get married when I was
when I met her I was 43 and she was only
20 if you want to know what happened
search for my name married to uh the
Russian mob
um see Dumbledore me me me me me there's
a reason single mothers were scoring for
all of human history except the last 30
years Alex Oliveira a women majority of
the time she's the man that is probably
going to cheat on them plus a submissive
wife isn't the same thing as a slave um
shout out from Brazil Pearl ali um
thoughts on having a few wives I'm down
for it look at me and yes her sister wow
see dumbbell dorf it's all a tone police
if it's not flattering to women but it's
fine to say I don't want no scrubs when
dissing wet man this is this woman's son
is absolutely doomed I'm
dmaccially
these tattoos bring zero sex appeal um C
Dumbledore um can you explain what
feminine means your honor the men roster
case for generations of women lost to
history
um nefarious bro in the back um with the
cap is cold linked fax machine he has
real life example adds a lot to the
conversation
um numbers guy going overseas without
game only makes you a bigger Mark than
when you were at home these women are in
it for survival not vanity and
entitlement see Dumbledore stepping in
or out of a mindset is totally normal
for women being a chameleon is a
survival skill having one foot out
always out the door and an escape plan
is just their NDA or their DNA
um da truth um Filipina uh P went went
in on women bashing passports um numbers
guy show idea plain English only no
buzzwords numbers guy Western culture is
so pervasive that these passport Bros
need to become expat rows if they're
serious about a lifelong partner um Joe
pyo Sarah messed up round two let's go
I'll like the video numbers guys zero
this is why peers can't get a good job
actually real quick just to see if
there's any more Super chats um guys
make sure you subscribe we're really
close to 750k the the L yeah so close I
thought we hit it the L Factor there is
no voice in the space for men who had to
initiate divorce because of a bad wife
93 toe pie please look up um Sunita Soto
she burned her boyfriend's house Chris
could you do a show titled do women do
modern women lack empathy
oh that'd be a good show maybe
um DM me remind me we've done divorce
last week we were talking about we don't
do divorce on divorce last week right
um I know but we just never
you know because they talk about 30 of
men initiate divorce roughly right um
but you know a lot of them I don't think
want to it's just because like you know
in one in four marriages are sexless
um
it's not like the wives are doing a
great job so a lot of like a lot of them
I had one guy um email me and he just
basically
um because I get these stories all the
time but this is just one that came to
mind where he's like I make six figures
um I love my wife but I don't think I
was her first choice because um I have
the kids and she stopped sleeping with
me after like we had the kids she's a
good wife I want to stay married to her
but I don't know what to do like these
girls flirt with me all the time they
hit on me all the time I don't want to
cheat on her but she's not sleeping with
me and every time I bring it up she'll
give me pity sex which is like worse
remember last week last week I said that
men love idealistically and women love
opportunistically yeah you know and I
totally believe that I think women love
when the opportunity presents itself and
which is why women have always got a man
sniffing around their vagina somewhere
because they're looking for the
opportunity to get the better deal
listen man no but you remember okay okay
right but listen you see in Clinton you
see in regards to your man you were
talking about right just in general you
see in regards to your man you were
talking about and you said he cheated a
lot right or he cheated a couple of
times he wasn't trying to leave you was
he no he still wanted to get back with
me and that's the point when when women
step out they're stepping out they're
going to leave
if he'll have them if the guy if the guy
will have them emotionally already a man
will have sex with a hole in the wall
it doesn't it doesn't matter
yeah but they're saying they're not
doing it because they're emotionally
attached to the person they're having
sex with whereas woman if a woman
stepping out it's different she's she's
looking for a better opportunity yeah
it's usually on an emotional level if a
woman cheats then there is some kind of
emotional attachment there whereas a lot
of the time meant cheat and they say it
means nothing it's a hole it's a hole
it's meant nothing to me like do you
believe it yeah and ultimately that's
why do you believe that that's why it's
more Insidious but I think my ego when I
was younger my ego couldn't deal with it
so as I got older like removing my ego
from the situation I can objectively
look it and understand that yeah what
you've just said when I was like 18 19
20 I was like I got mine I was very cute
I mean could you love me no a man can
actually cheat on you and still love you
I heard because my emotions were in I
heard that like um some guys cheat and
then treat their girlfriend better
because they feel kind of bad yeah
a girl says I slept with your man you
should respond and say I know I know he
just bought me a Birkin you know what
I'm saying you're doing a good job yeah
thank you I think that kind of how I got
Moby though the thing is there you go
well I sold it to Sarah's point of men
would have and I'll give you an example
of men
well not just not just corn but one of
my brother's friends was in the Navy and
there's an Old Navy trick when men are
out in the seafood for a very long time
they pack a bunch of uh like liver
chicken liver lamb liver into a jar and
then have sex with the job so you got to
realize ladies that is the point in
which we're willing to go down chicken
liver but what I'm saying is
some guy at home
but what I'm saying is that when you
when when a man cheats you've got to
realize that the person is cheating with
might as well be a jar of chicken
that's not and that's better that is
gonna take us on to our second video but
where's the second video the second
video is not uh it's from Zoom to
Thailand so it's not it shouldn't be
okay okay I think that should be fine
yeah that should be fair
um blessing uh let's play the second
video please my friend ladies and gents
have a look at this
hmm I've seen this I think I've seen it
as well oh there's a girl's like I'll
steal your man be here and today's
question is what do women think of men
who leave their home countries to see
cloud in foreign lands well apparently
there's quite a lot of words going on
between a certain segment of Western
women and men who pursue International
relationships it seems there's a lot of
animosity against these guys with
name-calling and outrageous accusations
the conflict centers around a movement
called the passport Bros who are
typically black guys who have gotten fed
up with the situation in the west and
decided to look elsewhere for a happy
life now even though the passport Pros
are mostly African-Americans I think
you'll recognize the same tactics being
used to shame any guy who dares to dream
of finding a better mate overseas
so what are these women saying about the
man passport Pros go to third world
countries and purchase little girls and
turn her into a breeding mayor they're
little girls you're sick
hey
Majestic creature
[Music]
wow
let's go let's keep going yeah keep
going keep going I thought it was over
it sounds like the guys just want to
find greener pastures and their women
don't seem to like him very much anyway
so what's the problem
well let's listen to how one woman
describes the passport brow phenomenon
black women are you ready
apparently there's a group of you
guessed it black men who have grown
weary of the quote control that black
women have over them so they've decided
to seek dominance elsewhere and that's
in the form of traveling to third world
countries to seek a bride
what's at play here is that these Dusty
mediocre at best so-called men have
finally come to the realization that
black women are no longer willing to
settle for the bare minimum and are
choosing to stay single and maintain
their peace
if divesting to desperate and
disenfranchised women is so great why do
you all have to make an announcement a
grand announcement
oh I know why because you actually think
that this will hurt black women so
sayonara
great production value okay thank you
thank you thank you
look you see that girl she was so pretty
I'm like I don't understand why they're
going listen like like she's beautiful
I'm gonna say this and um that woman
made it specific to race about we
already saw that from the previous video
men from Europe are also doing the same
thing right
um from the peers video like you know
European men are doing the same thing
um
so
right because you know because I already
know people can be like oh my God we're
talking about black issues this is not a
black issue folks okay it's not a black
issue because if you read if you read
that or if you saw the other video it's
not a black issue
um I'm gonna ask this
to the women oh
do you want to get married
and if you do do you think that your
wife material
oh how do you stop it I'm like I'm gonna
let someone else
do you think your wife material uh no I
don't think I'm wifey material now like
I'm not wifey with her at all like with
cooking and stuff like because I live
with my parents
so like someone my mother is like the
the person who's in charge of the whole
household you they she cooks and
everything so I don't think I'd be
materialistic wife now maybe in the
future yeah are you are you trying to
learn to be aware I think in the future
I would definitely try to learn but for
now I'm just like YOLO no I don't really
care about like
I cannot I can't even crack an egg oh
wow
I don't care I at least I can clean it
oh now I'm just like YOLO because I'm
not gonna get married I've got a lot of
years to catch up but yeah I've got a
lot of years too yeah just ladies okay
you're 18. do you think you're worth
material do you think you're worth
material so I think I'm my material uh I
do think I'm wife material but I also
think that that's gonna that's quite
subjective so I think men might find
white material to different men it's
going to be different things they might
look for different things in a wife you
know what I mean but if you you're
asking me if I'm wife material I'd say
yeah I think what do you think makes you
worth me too
um so I think a lot of those like
feminine attributes that we spoke about
earlier so being nurturing and being
caring
um allowing yourself to be led by the
right man
um yeah and I you know I want to take
care of my man I want to take care of my
home I want to take care of my family
those are all things that I want to do
and I think those are all things that
you know you can fall under being good
wife material so the later on the video
the Filipina P shout out to the Filipina
P
um looks like that's going to be my wife
I'm not into Filipino women but it's
just you know whatever
um she understands what it is or the
women generally in those countries it
seems like they generally understand
what it is that men want in a wife okay
um
do you think you can compete
with women like that
yeah yeah yeah okay uh yes you don't
know me though so how can you say that
no yeah no I wasn't talking I was
talking
you haven't seen me anymore you have
kids don't you yeah yeah how many just
two how would you compete with a single
childless woman is she single and
childless Filipino yeah yeah yeah okay
well I guess so guys
um Tanisha says subjectively yeah if
he's looking for I didn't say wife
material so you said you you I thought
you were talking in terms of like wife
material in the aspects of being fit in
your feminine and you're talking about
just Purity if that is the only standard
that we're talking about then obviously
Knox and can't yeah so I can't compete
with Purity no you know you know how
women like the the top 20 over six foot
x amount of money do you know the top 20
for men if they had the choice and the
option to do do you know what those that
that category of women will be no
children it'll be a single virgin woman
that's pretty much the top one or two
percent I'm not struggling but what I
mean is I'm sure you'll be fine there's
the simps everywhere but
yeah of course of course but what I mean
is that that is the top 20 for men is
that single attractive thin woman that's
what we're all aiming for now some of us
fall uh you know basically we settle uh
for simping or whatever else but I
promise you that as much as if you go
with a five foot six or five foot eight
man who's earning forty thousand pounds
a year and you're settling for if a man
is going with a woman who's had two
children he is settling yeah but that's
okay
it's really difficult to find like I
think it would be difficult to find
someone when you've got two kids and
you're a single mother I mean
think of it from the guy's perspective
let's say in his early 20s comes with
mum I found a girl I'm 35. no but just
say he says Mama found a girl oh really
son you found a girl yeah who is she
this girl she's got two kids
but even more time all right let's say
even if your son's let's say your son is
40 now okay well if he's 40 then if he
loves him
it's not mine it's not mine wait wait
because didn't he behind us say that
there's different pools right no but I'm
sorry if your son's wife if your son's
40 you would think his first choice
should be someone with kids well what if
he had bipart
so what's wrong with him why doesn't he
even if he even if he does even even
okay even if he had kids why would he
pick a woman with kids over a woman
without like this shouldn't because if
she doesn't have children if she doesn't
have children she may not have a level
of understanding that he might need for
him having his children over in the
house and all of these different
elements that go into having a child
even if you're a man if you're looking
after if you're co-parenting you're
going to have them children on your own
if you've got a woman that's going to
want your undivided attention and you're
not able to give it that might give it
he don't understand men like when you
say that I hear it because you're
speaking from a woman's perspective well
I can only do that yeah of course but
you don't but as a man and as men here
we know that if we're going to pick a
woman for our long-term part
we're not trying to find some single
moment yeah I mean Sarah you you have a
son I have a son and I understand that a
lot of women would negate me because I
haven't because I have a son yeah
because I've probably got quote unquote
baggage that I could be bringing with me
right so I understand maybe mama drama
baby mama drama whatever it is right and
I understand that but yeah and I
understand that I'm not every woman's
first choice
a lot of the time
single mothers are understandable
they're not men's first choice I
understand yeah I understand that but I
also think like you're kind of will you
go with me somebody that I used to date
but you literally said to me but you
guys are answered like even when I ask
you a simple question like I'll say okay
if he's 40 and he who should his first
choice be you guys will still not give
it to you the answer
I gave you my genuine answer just
because it is no I don't I just think
it's not honest well that is my honest I
wouldn't say I've been honest in every
other element if my son was 40 and he
met somebody who he truly loved and was
and had children and she had and she had
children that should be his first choice
as his mother it's not my job to tell
him what to do at 40 years old
because he raised this man yeah
and he should be able to make a if I
haven't done my job good enough today at
40 years old that he can't make a
decision on his own he needs to come to
Mummy to ask him
can I just interject with a more
realistic scenario which in fact
breastfeeding too
every day
um but sign language but as far as a
real situation which actually I know
someone who exactly in this position
there were 27 28 with a
brilliant business really successful
already had two houses uh married a
woman a single mother at 37. would you
allow yourself
the person I know was 20 yeah
single mother well how am I allowing
like you're saying allowing as if I have
control no no but what I mean is would
you be happy with that yeah yeah I want
her to come home with her kids are you
gonna want her to uh are you going to
tell your son yeah bring go on bring the
girl
100 100 if my son is happy and he comes
home to me and say mum this is the woman
that I love and I am going to marry her
and these are 100 who am I to tell him
oh yeah right I do agree and I'm very
I'm very nurturing
but as his mother as his mother as his
mother your opinion matters
okay let me finish let me femininity
isn't cutting me off so it's like as you
as his mother your opinion matters right
and so it's like you could say oh son I
don't think that's maybe a good idea or
you would say it's a good idea
why would he come home and ask for my
opinion though because he values
do you go home every time you get in a
relationship do you go home and ask your
market I'll say this when I got with I
was in a previous relationship for 10
years right and I got with a single
mother and when I never had any children
right and I I specifically remember my
mom saying
I don't know son this might not be the
one but I know you say you love her but
I don't know and the thing is my mum
turned out to be right
um but also right because my mom as a
woman of age who's already had her
children she could foresee the future
that I couldn't see I'm in love Mama
love this woman yeah I'm great she's
thinking a down the road son there was
no red pill there was no manosphere to
help me out when I was in that situation
I just had my mum and I didn't listen to
her do I wish that I would have hell
[ __ ] yeah because my mom had a had an
insight and a wisdom that I didn't have
so as a mother you have an insight and a
wisdom that your son doesn't have so
what so when your son comes to you
in his 20s or whatever and says Mama
found a woman and you know she's got
children and you are you literally gonna
be like yeah yes and that's the one oh
you're gonna be like
yeah come on
yeah
and I think there's a difference between
sitting your son down and being like son
you haven't got kids yet she's got kids
are you sure about this do you
understand them
with this are you ready for this I think
there's a difference between having that
conversation and being like Oh my God no
no no this is wrong you should go you
said you're what 37 two children
would you let if you because you know
yourself yeah would you let your son
Choose You
um a woman just like you two children 37
and he's in his would you let your son
she's all just like I would probably say
no because I just wouldn't want to put
that pressure on someone that's 27 right
for me I just wouldn't feel comfortable
being with someone at 27 and I'm just
saying like I've got this comes with a
lot of responsibility we're probably
different life stages you know what I'm
saying so for me it's probably going to
be a no and that's what I'm saying I
would have that conversation with my son
but ultimately it's his decision
of course yeah so I would have that
conversation you've given some advice
yeah I've given some advice and like you
said there's that foresight that insight
there yeah because you've got it right
exactly but I just think if he doesn't
have kids like it doesn't matter how
nice she is like I would tell him to not
deal with her because she's got kids
I would say just like yeah like and it's
just it's not personal it's just like
that's a lot of that's a lot of
responsibility yeah exactly and you
didn't make that decision and you're
going to be the one responsible for it
I'm gonna I'm gonna be a little bit
crude but um yeah I mean the person that
I that I'm talking about they eventually
got divorced and uh they did he does
have a daughter from from that marriage
but um generally I saw it coming in my
advice was straight up pumping up me
pump and dump pumping up do you know
I've got you know what I've got to say I
thought I don't think women in the west
one I think one of the reasons why men
are opting to go abroad to find wives
women in the west don't value marriage
and a lot a lot of them say that they
like marriage and they want to get
married they don't value them and the
reason why I say that is because this in
the west marriage is a TV show 90 Day
Fiance love at first sight divorce court
right that's what marriage has become in
the west right so a lot of the time
women say they want to be married
too sorry that too whatever it is you
can add whatever because there's too
many things when it comes to marriage
that marriage is actually a TV show it's
not it's not real life like it's not
there's no sanctity in it anymore and so
yeah it's entertainment do you know what
I'm saying and so women that are outside
of the West don't see marriages
entertainment they see it as something
very like sanctimonious right yeah the
sanctity in it but in the west yeah
they're usually brought no but I think
in the west they usually brought up like
to be
oh like you're gonna grab your daughter
to be oh you're gonna be a stay high
wife I want you to find this doctor man
and I want you to get married to him and
usually I think usually you know like in
Afghanistan yeah and is that where
you're from no okay no I'm Lithuanian
and Somalian okay yeah but in like for
example in a Muslim country
um I think girls are brought up yeah but
in Somali in Somalia yeah yeah but in
Somali it's like it's how people think
from back home is oh
um I want you to be a housewife and
you're going to like learn how to cook
you're going to learn how to clean every
day and that's what usually I think men
tend to look for oh like stay at home
wife clean all the time just you know
like that yeah so no they want a boss
babe yeah I want to go with the business
yeah yeah
no stay home with that so would you say
that you embody the more Lithuanian side
to you or the more someone no I would
I'm Muslim so I would want to be uh with
a Muslim man okay I would yeah Somali
man no okay
Lithuanian Lithuanian I've always grew
up with my Lithuanian like cider family
right yeah the Lithuanian Aunt they're
not Muslims
oh okay yeah I have another video that I
I want to show oh yeah let's do it let's
do it okay
um I this is shout out to Austin
Holloman do you know who that is no this
man so I met him when I was in Texas and
he moved to Brazil because he said
American woman in his vote in his um
words are that bad
really yeah yeah so he literally moved
his life from the beginning yeah
let's mentioned this before I'm sure of
her juice oh his name oh the Brazil yeah
yeah yeah it's actually yeah I've seen
some of his stuff yeah yeah it happened
I don't know him yeah it's really cool
you can see the Vlogs With the women
there and I'm like oh he never coming
back
let's see this
um so this is before he moved hello I am
back again and this guy Brazil
we're going to be talking about what
made me leave to go to Brazil
in other words what made me stop dating
in the United States I've touched if
you've watched my take talk to some of
my YouTube videos you can kind of get a
perspective help but I'm gonna break it
down today so and these are in order I
believe
from severity
why I stopped dating in the United
States
the number one thing
and we're going to say
this is a this is actually a bunch I'm
bringing down the number one thing
that's stopped me from dating the United
States
was the texting games and the phone call
games the game
so we're not gonna act brand new we know
this is a thing here
you have to have some sort of game and
people get game confused with Charisma
those aren't the same thing okay
Charisma is the sweet talking in the the
emotional aspect of her getting to like
you with your words
but when I say game I'm talking about I
get your phone number now let me wait
two or three days to call you back like
if you know alpha male strategy he says
he weighs 10 days to call a woman back
why the [ __ ] would I want to do that
okay I I and I get it but then that's
another thing they say oh you got to
pretend like you have options you have
to have you have to show you have
options don't blow her up all the time
text her in between five minutes uh you
know don't I've said before don't have a
routine uh all that [ __ ]
you know all this you have to have this
super strategy just to get to know
somebody or even if you just want to
smash somebody it's usually not just
it's like it's like all these tactics
that's why there's so many YouTubers and
dating coaches coming out that are just
blowing up because nobody can truly
figure this [ __ ] out right and if you're
somebody like me that's on their purpose
I'm trying to get my money right so I
can live overseas and get the hell out
of here
I don't have time for the game look baby
either you want to [ __ ] with me you
don't
and that's how my world works it's black
and white there is no in between
either you want to [ __ ] with me or you
don't
and that's what when you go to to Brazil
and I'm gonna compare each number to
when I went to Brazil when I went to
Brazil and I saw those texting games
disappear
and the the you know Eve that she
wouldn't give you her number or she
would give you her number ninety percent
of the time if she gives you her number
it's going somewhere in the United
States 90 of the time you give a check
your number it's not going anywhere then
it makes you wonder why
did you give me your number I mentioned
in a tick tock video a chick left a note
on my cartoon chicks left a note on my
car
and then I call or text
and then I can't even hook up a date
with you or hook up a time to see you um
why the [ __ ] did you leave a note on my
car um
I don't have time for that y'all that's
like a bunch of
[ __ ] nobody has time for the texting
games the communication games and number
two flaking okay uh
there is a high I don't care unless if
you're some sort of super rich man or
some celebrity there is a high flake
rate in the United States so we were
teenagers we knew this right now but I
had time for that when I was a teenager
like I didn't have a job or anything I
wasn't doing [ __ ] but going to school
and going home
when I went to the mall I had to get 10
numbers or if I went to Six Flags I had
to get 10 numbers why because out of 10
numbers only three of the [ __ ]
gonna text back I don't give a [ __ ] what
nobody says only three of those are
gonna text you back and I out of those
three two or maybe one or maybe two
you're gonna see again
it's it's just that
it's I don't care anybody tells you
otherwise it's full of [ __ ] unless if
there's some sort of celebrity but
they're not living the regular lifestyle
like this so as an adult
I knew that going okay probably still
the same thing I still gotta uh approach
a lot of women but then it was just
coming back like damn the flake rate it
seemed like the flake rate has gotten
worse and I know some dumbass watching
this video right now is gonna be like
look in the mirror look in the mirror
that's not the [ __ ] problem because
this there's a abundance of men saying
the same thing and then you hear about
these women wanting to uh just have
validation and social media and cell
phones have created this where they have
access to so many men they'll flake on
you in a minute
yeah
he's really funny though he always is
like modern women they're that bad
I I
um
I hear him with the games yeah yeah
those games like the tedious oh bro like
the thing is um with the flake rates
actually I would love the Pearl your
your opinion on this when it comes to
the Sexes men or women which one of them
flake on you more when it comes to
guests coming onto the show oh God I oh
I have strong hands
I have strong feelings I feel like a
dude I don't do the recruiting anymore
thank you Jesus oh my God I'm Catholic
but oh my god when I did the recruiting
it was like you get it the flag rate for
women if they said yes I will be at the
show 50 and half of them won't even tell
you they're not coming they just don't
show up the men
um I would say like 20 will flake on you
20. unless they're athletes the flake
rate goes up I don't know what it is
about that I'll be honest I had a woman
who said that she was gonna come today
the issue flake they always do yeah yeah
yeah except you guys good job
you know I was tempted
but yeah but those those texting that
those texting games are real like when
he said you even [ __ ] me you don't I
felt that yeah you know I mean
no but the thing is as women you're
already know that I ain't got time to
hear that because you as women you
already know that there are guys that
have got your number and you ain't gonna
text them back 100 I was having a
conversation with one of my female
friends and she was um it was it was an
Intrigue for me because I'm like why do
women give out their numbers the guys
are not interested yeah and he made a
good point when it comes to validation
and she was like sometimes I might be
bored we might not be interested in but
we might want to see where it's going
and I'm like you would never catch a guy
giving a number to a woman he is not
interested in it for one because any
holes a goal that's why they just want
to smash
well then if you don't want to smash
donkey I ain't got time for that don't
get your number yeah I don't give the
number don't get a number like there's
been times where I've been on the phone
I'm hearing it happen and she's saying
like I've got to give my number some
guys don't take Nova either which is a
fair point yeah they're like
sometimes it's actually easier to give
your number I'd give the wrong number
yeah yeah the wrong number but yes a lot
of them are texting back still a lot of
them are still communicating and a lot
of them are saying well I'm being boring
with my reply so he should take the hint
but I'm like if a guy knows you're gonna
reply whether it's a boring reply or not
you're still replying and to him he's
gonna keep texting yeah the thing is
this whole no women don't do honesty
very well that's what the thing it's not
I mean I've seen it there's an entire
strategy behind the the online game or
texting game
um I've got this entire thing mapped out
but as far as
is the whole thing about Plenty of Fish
but as far as women uh flaking on you
first of all I think some of that is to
do with like a woman gives you her
number but she wants to still be chased
so chase me Chase me so I feel some of
that is probably in that scenario where
women want to be chased I think still
women want to to get a man I think
they're running away from me
okay
for me and you guys can tell me if this
is true I feel like
um if guys there's three boxes immediate
yes immediate no
um on the no there's no coming out of
that you like never and then there's
like maybes yeah yeah and then so it's
like like maybe
um like I like something about them or I
don't maybe yeah and so if a guy's like
a maybe I feel like like I forgot if I'm
not responding like I feel like I'm just
not that into him I would hate to be a
maybe I prefer to be a no than a baby
that's why guys hit that yeah yeah I'd
hate I prefer to be a no that I mean I
think sometimes it's like you know I've
met something that you meet somebody and
you're like you know what they're like
you said there's so many attributes
about them you're like why don't like
what what is that missing so you think
because some relationships can grow over
time so it's like maybe you see and it's
that mentality that no I'm just saying
that that puts girls in positions where
they're giving out their numbers because
it's based on the presumption of hope
that it can grow into something even
though you're not interested at the time
and to piggyback off that the hope is
that he does something awesome that
makes you change your mind not you when
you walk into a relationship situation
where you're waiting for someone else to
make it good then you're not going to
put your best foot forward and it's
probably not gonna work yeah let me ask
a woman a question actually do you it's
random do you think that you have to
work for the guy or the guy has to work
for you I think it's both I think yeah
yeah I think yeah the t-way thing
definitely what do you think most women
think yeah
um
yeah I mean you asked me I'm telling you
my responses
do you think most women have some guys
where they're gonna go that extra mile
for and then there's like everyone else
yeah if I see potential in somebody I
100 go there the flakiness I haven't
really noticed much bleakiness in women
but he's acting like you know it happens
all the time
some guys it's bound to happen if you're
taking 10 to 20 numbers yeah
so if you're putting yourself out there
you're you're bound to come across
remember flaky I mean the thing is I
think a guy who looks like you probably
doesn't get as much flakes as a guy that
looks like me we come from different
words
we always go out and one of my friends
on regular basis like continues to get
five to ten numbers a night so if he's
getting five to ten ten numbers a night
he knows that out of that 10 he's
looking at possibly meeting two of them
by the end of the chains and and because
he knows how many to uh at least out of
ten numbers he'll get two of them that
he'll eventually get to the point of
actually going on a date okay and out of
those two uh potentially one of them is
probably a sexual partner and the other
one might flake on that so really we're
winding down to that I mean that's the
strategy that I said with POF is I start
on a Sunday and by Wednesday I am on a
telephone call by Thursday Friday I'm
arranging a date for either a Friday or
the Saturday and then out of those
Friday or Saturday dates potentially one
of them
how tall are you six four okay do you
think your experience would be different
if you maybe didn't have modeling
opportunities and you were five six we
come from very different worlds my
friend I mean you know I can never say
because I haven't been that but I could
imagine yeah I could imagine it might be
a little bit different but
there's still other things you can do I
do think guys should maximize
um their social skills fish in their
hole I think guys should learn Charisma
I think guys should maximize their looks
especially in the face and I think that
guy should go to the gym when you say
maximize her looks in the face how would
that how would that work working out
frequently not in their face oh in their
face yeah you know get a little shape up
you know get the Beards get a nice get a
nice haircut yeah I've seen some sorcery
yeah and they come out when they come
out because at the end of the day a
woman a woman has to sleep with these
guys at the end of the day it's just to
like what she sees a bit Yeah in the in
the pickup Artistry sort of uh
communities number one uh thing is the
number one thing puts women off is is
badly groomed yeah I've worked I've
worked I've worked I used to coach a
little bit of that to be honest and and
what being work rooms smelling good
we're we're in nice clothes not
expensive just things that's a tailored
to you shower yeah have style that
attracts the sorts of women that you
like I swear there's a Kevin Samuels
video of He's teaching men how to use
Lucas actually I'm curious you said
you've done dating coaching yeah you I
still do it you do it yeah I've just
studied it and oh you don't actually I
haven't I haven't okay I just I don't
how many clients have you had enough
that you could get a general picture
yeah okay because like the one thing I'm
curious
um a lot of the guys that do it are they
from single mother homes because I'm
thinking like it's just a hypothesis I'm
wondering if maybe they're not like
groomed okay no no
no that's a good question but no it's
actually really random okay it's really
random I could actually
I'll be better off breaking it down by
race but I'm not gonna do that here but
I'll be better off breaking about my
race actually
I want to say hello yeah you can you can
like Asian guys go for it a lot do you
feel that you guys go through what they
go for they they come to me a lot Asian
guys yeah they're the leaders all right
because because there's an American
audience here when we say Asian okay I'm
talking about
um
um and then you get uh I'd say European
like Caucasian and I'd say Black's kind
of the smallest yeah even though I think
a lot of them there's a lot of um I
think a lot of black men walk around
with a lot of ego and they wouldn't
really want to come yeah foreign
my friends that are from afro-caribbean
sort of backgrounds and and
they just have game no no we don't
always
let me let me
say something about that a lot of them
don't have games yeah but what it is is
that I've been a black man in in the UK
all of my life and I know that I can
when I used to go out to the club so
don't go out to the clubs anymore
but when I I could walk into a club with
mostly European women
and just get attention
I don't have game
but there's something in their heads
that when they see me objectively yeah
when they're like oh oh that guy right
so it's not necessarily game like I I
think a lot of black men are just
desired by other people other races
that's that's what I personally growing
up all of my life I'm 41 years old
that's me growing up in the UK saying
okay cool like I've been to all types of
situations do you think and and women
that women that aren't because you can
go to if we talk about there's a guy
that was actually in Thailand as a
matter of fact
um who's getting a lot of black men to
go to Thailand and there's a guy that
was walking around Thailand as a black
man and seeing the attention he gets
listen
I'm not saying it's a good thing bad
thing I'm just saying in certain
scenarios and you know as a black man
they just desired you know do you think
it's because
um like you know like if you're not
allowed to have something you then want
to typical so like it's like they're
maybe culturally their families may be
like no you could be and so it's more
desirable because it's like yeah
it's for sexual pleasure it's not
necessarily for a long-term you do have
to be a certain type of black girl as
well I like no Steve urkels getting all
that action
a nerdy like a nerdy kind of black guy
even even women don't tend to like dirty
black girls to be honest they don't
really get any play this is this is the
strangest thing because a lot of the
guys I know uh afro-caribbeans are I.T
guys the programmers hardcore like.net
ASP and they still get they still get
action but they've got game they they
walk into a game maybe the ones you know
and you can talk to everyone and anyone
that if I point those friends of mine I
was I mean when I was young I was scared
to death of talking to women women were
like alien creatures and a friend of
mine was from Ghana I point to any woman
he would straight up walk up to her and
start talking to her as a woman that
rejected three or four other guys before
before her before him and I said okay
that one he went up to her he was
sitting down talking to her for 50
minutes
because in other cultures
whether they be
um South Asian whether they be African
socialization is part of the culture our
culture do you know what I mean like
learning just how to speak to Auntie
so-and-so or even like it's just part of
our 100 culture that maybe that and also
you know
um being a black person trying to you
know get jobs and stuff you kind of have
to be funny you kind of have to like
make people think you're less threatened
yeah so you have to learn all these
skills yeah you learn all these skills
along the way that make you just happen
to be great with women sometimes you
know and and so that's what it is it's
not necessarily a game it's just
interesting social skills
um I'm gonna ask another question
uh on topic do you think the reason for
the men or sorry do you think the reason
for women over here being less desirable
is
the f word
the word the f word feminism Oh I
thought you I was like what's saying it
there's a reason why men are finding
women over in the west so this is I
think it's alienates it's feminism yeah
I think the alienate smell I think it
gives um
I think it gives women a false kind of
um
sense of entitlement and I think that it
makes them feel like victims even though
they probably weren't even alive
whether times were a lot better exactly
so they don't even read what already
happened and I think that um it makes
them feel like the victim so it gives
them the right to act a certain way and
treat men a certain way and it's it's
quite sad really because I think we both
lose it's because we're at feminism
allowed women to be bailed out of every
single bad decision that we make ever
like if we want to if we want to sleep
around there's birth control yeah if
that doesn't work we have abortion if
that doesn't work you can get um
government assistance for being a single
mother if that doesn't work
um you can you know marry someone it
does could be the father of your kid
could not
um and then you know leave him and take
half yeah
[Laughter]
I did not get a penny again
and then and then on top of that like um
foreign
I mean men you know commit like suicide
a lot of times after these divorced so a
lot of times like women make bad
decisions at the expense of man it also
allows us if we want to be homeless
there's women's shelters too like
there's actually um for this hospitals
for men as well
there's a friend of mine
there was a friend of mine who was in
Iran and he was talking to this lady
who's like the Auntie of his wife a
woman that he was about to marry and she
said how many houses do you have in in
England he said I'll just have the one
house it was really you only have one
house I have two houses he said yeah
that's because I didn't get divorced
twice
[Laughter]
what do you think um with the beautiful
majestic creatures
they say it's like Cheaper to Keep Her
Like why yes yes like why is that a
phrase yeah it's true so feminism is one
of the reasons I think why the men are
flocking to outside of the West because
feminism is messed up it also confuses
um women about like what men actually
want I mean how many I've had girls on
the show that like genuinely think that
men care about your job they don't give
a [ __ ] and they don't care about body
count yeah no they actually do care
about your body can yeah and we don't
care about your job
yeah you know what I mean I mean I mean
I think
how many girls clothes I have called Liz
who attends
that's wild yeah what are you gonna say
go ahead no I was gonna say that like
obviously if you're dating in your like
your pool and you've got an amazing job
job then surely you you want a partner
that like matches you in some math work
so your job not necessarily I don't know
man so maybe not maybe not all men but I
think I think the demographic men who
want their women to actually be
successful successful in some divisions
I don't care about a woman's job what
she does but I want it to not be not
involve her being naked or anything like
that and I want it to be something that
she enjoys
um and
that's about it really yeah like I I you
know that's it but there's still a level
and I wanted to have one it would be
nice if she has one yeah so it's like
women like we're attracted to the CEO of
a company like I've used this example
before but Donald Trump and Melania okay
I don't I'm not talking about politics
but who's better looking him or him or
Melania right she's better looking and
it's not the same thing for Oprah
like there aren't men lining up to bang
Oprah but there's there's I'm sure
Donald Trump even look Donald Trump even
looking how he does has women lined up I
just like this I just like to say Oprah
if you ever see this I am willing to do
this
I am willing and capable
statues
you're gonna give her a ring too I am I
am well I mean I may not be able to
afford the kind of ring she can never
but we can maybe put it on like payment
plans maybe at her credit card no I I
think like I said when it comes to
feminism like
the reason why you know men are opting
out like women you've done many Street
interviews Perl when you've asked women
about like body count does body count
matter and they're like no body count
doesn't matter because if a man worries
about body count then he's a it's like
yeah this is why I'm gonna run the title
like this is why men are going outside
because body count matters yeah yeah it
doesn't matter to women sometimes I get
it but to men 100 yeah because I fully
believe that I mean even if a man tells
you I don't care about it just tell me
as soon as you tell them
do not tell him ladies this is how I
know it matters because if there's a
woman that I think is amazing
I probably won't ask yeah yeah
if she's that amazing but the problem is
with that body count comes certain
behaviors and habits and and also ethics
I think and and morals and that will
permeate through your relationship so
you may not know her brother yeah
exactly nobody can I think I've got a
really good barometer for that I can
tell well you know so yeah
I can pretty much tell I think most guys
can tell if someone's uh
had a lot of people
I don't know how can you tell how can
you be surprised it's a feeling it's an
attitude and a lot of the time those
women tend to be less feminine actually
funnily enough
um
because every it's like every body
there's more trauma exactly and so and
no just being real like unless you're
unless you're the type of girl that
doesn't attack right which I don't think
men typically want
um like there's more trauma with each
guy you're with and so that's why guys
can smell a high body count
energetically you also take the shot
smells blood trust me every time you're
with somebody you're taking on their
energy I mean for me I do think
sometimes people have had many lives in
a sense of you you can get someone that
you know has had a high body count but
they've completely kind of turned that
around and they're not like that anymore
I asked I asked my dad this question I
said dad okay because I was with a
boyfriend he didn't really like
um but I was like Dad do you think like
people change over time and he says yes
they get worse so whatever Behavior you
see that you don't like like it's going
to be worse yes 30 years and I just
think like you can you can hide it and
some simp won't see it but if you have
like you're gonna have behaviors that
are going to show you show him exactly
what like what you are and I just don't
think like you can hide it forever yeah
like it's hard to be like you said five
I just heard about this x that X that
accent yeah might allow it because they
don't think they can do better yeah yeah
that's what happens quite often if you
had like 30 dicks inside you right and
like you're gonna like a guy will
eventually see that you've had 30 dicks
inside you you will eventually because
the thing is your like you said your
behaviors will show it
that is that is why women who have had
most women who have had more than what
five bodies are more likely to get
divorced or your chance your chance to
have a happy marriage and okay people
don't like this study so there's a
couple different ones but
um if you're a virgin on your wedding
night you have an 80 chance of a happy
marriage there's a couple studies that
say 60 to 70 percent so it depends which
one but it drops to a 25 chance after
like five to seven Partners so you're
basically ruined after like five to
seven because yeah because you're okay
because you're comparing your guy
whoever country or subconsciously to
those guys and you're like was he like
that was he like that guy is he like
that guy for me for me an analogy of the
body counting for women is it's kind of
like um when you first get on the
internet and you check the comment
sections and you see all the people
talking bad about you and giving you
more and more [ __ ] eventually you
desensitize to it you become you know
you be you harden effectively and you no
longer get affected as much by the
comment section as you used to when you
first did and that is the same with
women who have more and more Partners is
eventually you're you are not because
you get hurt you get heartbroken you
this is a coping mechanism within a
human being they don't want to be hurt
anymore and your body will figure out a
way to protect you from being hurt and
that will mean usually you will become
more of a distant person and you will
never fully commit yourself to uh to the
next relationship because you know that
the previous one really hurts but you
also know the one that felt really good
the alpha Widow that as well you know
the one that felt really good and you're
like
I actually have a question for the guys
yeah would you take a girl okay she's
got um
what would you guys say is a high body
count hi just give me give me a number
twenty five twenty could we say 20 is
high yeah yeah okay that's like medium
high yeah um okay so let's say
really high okay so let's say 25 yeah
okay her body counts 25.
um however she's never she's never okay
she's never gone back to an ex ever or
you can date a girl that's had five but
there's one X she's been sleeping with
on and off
for seven years that's a good question
on every relationship that ends that's
the guy she goes back to oh yeah she's
done she's awful with it no which would
you pick or which would I pick yeah
her body counts 25 yeah
um again all things equal looks
everything else is equal one girl's body
counts 25 she's never gone back to an ex
the other girl's body count is five
I'm picking the X I'm picking I'm
picking the one with 25. 25 yeah that's
wild really yeah so you would pick the X
yeah because I mean I'll tell you why
yeah if she keeps going back to the same
guy she's kept going back to the same
guy after the breakup yeah yeah if she
keeps doing that um is it only after the
breakup where she's been is a funny
business going in between
um you don't know this is just bro you
know there has to be an emotional if I
if I actually believe
that she's only going off but back to
that X after the breakups yeah then I'll
go with the one with five and the
boyfriend 100 25 guys or more but but I
would have to really trust her yeah I I
don't know why
fam I feel like I feel like I feel like
I would recommend the one I don't think
I'd recommend it yeah yeah I'll get rid
of both of them to be fair but like but
I feel like if that's you I feel like
the one that's more dangerous is the one
that keeps like the situation there's a
situationship for six years yeah it'll
be on my mind that's why I said that but
I'm saying if we've built up that level
of trust if we've spoken about it and I
you know I I don't trust and I hardly
trust anybody to be honest wow so why
because
when a richer anyway so so no but like I
would I'll choose if we've got a certain
level of trust and also part of me would
believe that like you know I you know
I'd re-alph a widower
that would be my my Outlook anyway I
might not be right but I wouldn't be
threatened by the way
what if he was Michael B Jordan
[Laughter]
is because he chose Laurie Harvey yeah
right and Lori Harvey had been passed
around the industry
but the thing is his choice in women is
skewed yeah he's got he doesn't know
he's doing yeah
one thing I just want to say between the
two women that you described uh for me
the analysis is actually one of them is
actually a tester and the other one is
an investor the the strategy some yeah
it goes back to pick up Artistry but the
women have personality types some women
are testers and some women are investors
some women go out with multiple men just
to find the one that is the closest to
the one that they ideal their ideal man
whilst other men other women go out with
one guy and invest in him in order to
make him the guy that they actually want
and the first one with the five and
keeps going back to the old ex-girl
boyfriend is the investor type who is
trying to get this guy to become the one
that she wanted whilst a woman with 2025
plus she's a test that she'll test you
out if the next guy comes your monkey
branch and and you look so so to make it
clear I picked the right one
yo
false say I want to thank everyone for
coming through we have been on air for a
couple of hours now you know we've
already had one person leave
um it was too late I'd like to say she
didn't like she didn't Pearl Castle
herself oh is that a new one now Pearl
Castle I've never I've never done it but
you never know it could be I've been
getting less patient lately Power Castle
that might be a thing
um but yeah thank you all for coming
um we're gonna thank you wrap the show
up now
um before we do wrap the shop can I just
get everybody's final thoughts on the
subject we'll start over there
um as a yeah I don't have any final
thoughts I think I've given quite a
descriptive my thoughts in quite detail
throughout the show
um yeah thanks for having me no problem
thank you
um yeah can I just plug yeah you can
find me I've just reached a thousand
subscribers on power on shimbally so go
there and find me there what's that
what's that it's my YouTube channel
uh and also I'm on Twitter and I don't
have Instagram yet uh but as far as the
final thoughts are concerned men who are
the average guy pretty much I I think I
fit the mold on that
um yes do look elsewhere unfortunately
the West has has done is gone it's it's
a lost cause Western women whether you
think their their trades or not they are
feminists no matter what they say to you
feminism is the cancer that has already
seeped into the West it's a lost cause
go to Southeast Asia or or the Middle
East I thought you said you didn't
struggle here you said in your no no no
no no for marriage sorry sorry for
marriage for for Pump and dumps Europe
is your golden ticket
all day every day feminism is the
greatest thing that happened to a man
who wants to get laid Yeah
yeah but but if you want to get married
look elsewhere because I think Europe is
done I'm sorry
yeah
I would say ladies if you are not a
virgin and you're a single mother do not
go and curl up in a quarter and die
you don't have to pump and don't worry
no you're worth but it's been it's been
amazing it's been really insightful it's
been really good like hearing who hurt
you opinions
yeah that's my final thought
okay um final folks I think I think
ultimately women in the west are
brought up differently to women in other
countries they're brought to be
independent and sort of to fight for
equality whereas other women in
different cultures are brought up to
serve the man I'm not saying that's the
sole purpose of what a woman's job is
but that's that's you know woven into
their characteristics and DNA so it only
makes sense that if you're looking for
someone who's going to be submissive to
you you're going elsewhere if you're
being logical
um at the same time on the flip side I
understand the grip of the women
criticizing the men because
as a black guy if I saw a group of black
women promoting we're leaving black men
to go to white women or whatever
different race of women well sorry white
man here excuse me I would understand
lesbian how I would feel
um if it's about publicizing it and
making it a movement so I can understand
that somebody's
irritation towards a group of men
um making a movement basically but yeah
that's my final thoughts on it
um
I would say
on both sides of the spectrum it's fine
if you're a guy that's having a lot of
trouble uh if you're just like super
mediocre or below mediocre and you're
having loads of trouble you can't be
bothered to
work on your social skills and by all
means go abroad and there's literally I
don't think you deserve judgment for
that to be honest right however
if you don't want to travel all the way
to another country because you like it
where you are and you just want to
improve
I would say
go on the internet look at loads of
videos or if you want to save yourself
some time
contact me
um my Instagram is Aaron Beasley and my
YouTube channel is the rmbz original and
uh if you want to go on my link Tree on
my Instagram you can get an empowerment
call with myself right but also guys and
girls you know always remember that we
have to love each other we have to try
and make it work right and
um I just like Terence said you know I
can understand why women will be you
know feel a certain way about guys going
to another country and making it a
movement
but women
come on man you've got to be a bit nicer
to the to the normal guys out there man
you know because a lot of the women that
are being less than kind to these normal
guys
are also normal women
and and you know we all have a lot of
baggage and we just need to give each
other a lot more understanding
remember Aaron bz on Instagram
so I decided today I want to do a final
thought yeah
I want to be included
but today I decided I'm going to so
um first of all I understand why they're
leaving and I think as modern women we
should try to learn from the women
overseas and ask what they're doing
right and what we can do to keep them
this day rather than shaming the men
that are leaving um I think they have
their reasons and if men are going to a
different country we're probably doing
something wrong so we should probably
pick it up
um second off about being a single
mother it's not over if you're a single
mother if you're really hot
[Music]
it probably is over because this is what
I heard from the mat and this is me I
don't make the rules I just tell you
what they are I guess if you're an a if
you're an a each kid is at least a point
subtracted so you you automatically is
sick so if you're an eight maybe a nine
you might get away with it if not tough
luck um I would maybe learn to cook or
maybe do some other skills maybe get in
the gym I don't know but it's gonna be
tough to compete with a single childless
women like me out here anyway
I thought you couldn't work on these
things to then put yourself in a pace
did you not hear me talk about wife
school yeah yeah
basically get a BBL or die train okay I
mean you can't you can't get rid of your
child
not after your birthday
my final thoughts are this
um follow me Sarah Garvey on all uh
social medias that's done and
um yeah I actually think that men who go
abroad to find love
um are probably doing the right thing
because I don't think that Western women
generally
given feminism and all the other isms
and schisms
um are the best women to be with so yeah
guys if you want to get your passport
passport Bros go get your passport fly
out to Dominican Republic Brazil
Philippines Thailand South Africa East
Africa
grab your passport and go um I
personally went to Kenya and uh
and
um yeah um other than that uh if you
ever watched two or more of our videos
tell them and you have not subscribed
then we have Whopper beef well we got
beef exactly so you better get doing
that right now thank you all for joining
and let's get sorrow to a hundred
thousand yeah let's get me to a hundred
thousand go on my YouTube man and get me
to 100K come on guys and girls uh so I
have
um a couple of recommendations because I
did grow up with nannies from around the
world
um so a couple countries that I I would
recommend that make good wives so first
of all Brazilian women are great they're
very feminine um however with the kids
they kind of used to let us do whatever
we wanted so I knew if I had a Brazilian
Manny they would let us do whatever but
they're really good with kids a lot of
fun
um also Germany
um those women typically are more they
are feminist however they they cap
they're submissive in the kitchen for
their man in their rooms yeah and
they're they're very skinny and in
shapeful um
I went to a wedding in Germany and I was
impressed I was like damn these are I
see why they're leaving us you've seen
German shot Putters
okay maybe maybe not all
okay maybe it was just the wedding music
anyways anyways um just two countries
Amsterdam's decent too but it's like the
same thing Philippines I guess Cambodia
I don't know I wouldn't have nannies
from those countries
I'm not saying these are the only
countries you can go to I'm just saying
when I had nannies I really liked the
Brazilian and German ones that's a kid
so yeah we thought they were good
anyways
um I'm gonna read the super Chats on the
way out yeah guys like the video
subscribe to the channel let's get to
750k
um stormy blue um reality check not a
feminist if you drink milk zero Fallout
the West is done for the average man
they're mad because their retirement
plan is disappearing only 20 of women
will get a high value man and the rest
will be leftovers trying to retire with
a gump
um stormy blue staff virgin even it's
not bad or difficult thank you Pearl for
up uplifting valuable women Robert Humes
ever since the simp joke the girl on the
far right makes the most priceless faces
every time the guys guy in the cap talks
and I love it um big trucks reviews any
body count more than one me is a high
body count
um see Dumbledore if we don't care about
your money you're never spending it on
us we don't care about your job the more
you work the less time you have for us
and and the more you have to and the
more you have to complain about woke his
Panther got in the Hat how much would
Oprah have to pay you to eat that box
Jonathan Jonathan Farley when Obama got
elected president a 19 year old Albanian
girl turned to me and congratulated me I
was 38. she later wanted us to meet to
have glue gluey one I didn't bother to
tell her I didn't vote for Obama thank
you Barack
um Adventures of Sam I divorced an
American woman over games and went back
to traveling traveling my Colombian
Colombian woman is 25 years younger no
kids educated and Wealthy get your
passport um NSX passes ten dollars onto
King riches for a beer after his last
stream patience of a saint
um yeah this girl self-casseled herself
so if you want to watch that go watch it
on King riches it's his last live Alex
Oliveira
um I don't know where this friend of of
yours lives but women here in Brazil are
typically like the women in the U.S UK
he is successful with women because they
see him as a gringo uh I've never heard
that word I'm curious a curious foreign
nkh women um want the wedding not the
marriage Stephen please buy some
knee-high socks keep up the good work
ancestral Ridge um we get it Doug MPA um
black women don't like you
um nefarious the amount of cope coming
from the dreads is off the chart the
fact that you don't want what's best for
your son after you became a single
mother is insane
um big truck review stepdad is like
financing another man's orgasm
women are like Geniuses they find
loopholes anywhere Doug MPA women will
sacrifice their sons for their feelings
um that's how deep missandry goes in the
black community and it's sad um see
Dumbledore all these I'm a 10 orcas need
to realize that men wanna five or a
woman half their size Filipina p is half
the woman is half the woman that these
tens are and that's why she's winning 90
free till probably 18 for how long I'm
Doug MPA Sweden is outlawed lying Thai
passports because their men are bringing
so many Thai women back with them to
marry and have babies the UK and the us
are going to have to do that soon okay
um women want to take men who want to
take their wives last name give me the
same Vibe as male feminists
um Edgar Ray's sea ladies you're getting
beaten by other women like her um Vinnie
Falcone women where does the lack of
character Heart personality rate looks
made as a self-described good man some
of these discussions leave me empty as
Society really this shallow hello sorry
dating is superficial it just is big
trucks on reviews thank you for a pearly
for taking over the manosphere the L
Factor there's no voice in this there's
no voice in the space for men who had to
initiate divorce because of a bad wife
um okay I think I read all these guys um
Let me refresh it real quick just to
make sure I don't miss any but subscribe
to the channel like the video on your
way out
um
a couple announcements before we end the
show um the first is that we have two
clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily go subscribe to both um we
also have four membership tiers so I'm
the first here lets you be a part of the
chat the second tier you get to be a
part of our Discord and our behind the
scenes Vlogs which includes me rapping
um third third tier you get to connect
with me on social media fourth tier you
get a one-on-one call with me once a
month go follow my Instagram just pearly
things one go follow my Tick Tock just
pearlythings.5 and six
um subscribe to wife school I think
we're almost to 2000 Subs we should be
dropping um wife School episode one
video this week right blessing this week
yeah
um thank you for the super chats thank
you for watching we'll talk to you next
time
foreign